and thanks for braving the New York City
spring cold my top is iphone on rails
they take a hike on trains but it is a
the idea as a safety system it's a
little motor boated mobile app also with
apologies to Francis calling it a mobile
app
I broke up the talk into a few sections
just to make it easier to keep track of
what section I'm in by the way I was
really nervous before but seeing so many
friendly faces here makes me feel much
more relaxed so a little bit about how
do you train control might be
application that i work on on the leap
technically textually and the product
manager for this program called Kozma
and talk about programming in cosmic
Cosmo players with our testing so let's
get on the positive train control one on
one has anyone here heard of positive
train control or has an idea what it
does not know about my former colleagues
please oh it's okay it is a good saying
safety system I federally mandated I
have to go into effect by to get full it
applies to all the +1 railroads and down
tracks and CSX my client is a class 1
railroad so it applies to CSS this is a
picture of a train wreck that's ember
2008 California he ran a train and
freight train collided and there were a
lot of casualties and within that same
month it doesn't seem like that long ago
but Congress passed that law within the
same month mandating positive train
control and all that plus 1 railroads in
EM track has to eliminate by December of
next year
what is positive train control it's an
automated safety system that is designed
to detect dangerous situations and warn
the crew that they must take action to a
birth danger and if the crew does not
respond it will actually work danger
itself by stopping the train climb rate
from stopping the train and this is a
display and that an engineer might see
when approaching a railroad switch a
switch is when it's a why in the tracks
and there's a controller on that switch
that tells the train which directs the
train to one track or the other positive
train control it's aware of all the suit
positions when it's safe to drive if the
suits position is unknown we train may
not pass that switch and the system is
telling it that i'm going to start
breaking soon estate one second if you
don't hit the brakes or self and then a
few seconds later positive train control
has actually applied the brakes to stop
the train ian event they over a very
dangerous situation which is going into
a switch where that's where the
direction is unknown and which could
cause it to go on a track where there's
another training at the crashing
together training
now to get this kind of system
implemented you can imagine that there's
a big impact on the railroad systems
relative systems that right now don't
know where every train is and the on
board the train it may not know
automatically what the next signal is
saying like whether it's red or green
whether I'm allowed to go through it or
have to stop or what my speed limit is
that's all up to the engineer to keep to
pay attention so that and the engineer
knows at all times where the train is
allowed to be how fast is allowed to go
but to implement positive train control
it both will fill need a lot of new
back-office servers some new wayside
devices that's physical devices along
the train tracks new communication
systems but also a lot of new equipment
right on board the locomotive and that's
where that's where my application comes
in so this is this is some of the local
locomotive with equipment and this is a
train computer it's the computer that's
actually listening to signals from
around in the environment figuring out
whether it's allowed to be where it is
deciding whether what's it what to say
to the crew displaying a graph of how
much braking distance the engineer has
before they need to stop the train and
make it counting down like I'm going to
start applying the brakes in 10 seconds
and then making the decision to hit the
brakes that's the own work pc computer
and there are some some displays that
the engineer and conductor can see like
we saw before the handbrake
for you this is a 220 megahertz radio
it's a it is being installed in
locomotives along with radio towers as
an additional communication stadium this
is a non-word routing server it's made
by GE exactly 21 more private servers
one at a time on a locomotive but it
could be one or the other this is one by
GE and this ground observer have access
to an AT&T cell or a Wi-Fi sell over I'm
sorry 18teen verizon why I can
communicate with that that radio that
showed on the previous image so it's the
communication system and the route the
network router the so with all this new
equipment on board that there is a need
to make sure it's running right and to
check it out and when there's a new
installed and and also to upgrade
software all on the devices when they
may need software upgrades and that is
where the cosna application comes in and
that's that's the application that my
team is working on it it's a it's an
agent that runs a locomotive agent in
this sense meaning program that's
running in an unusual location but that
gives it a big advantage to doing the
kinds of things that it needs to do from
that location and in my case the
location is on that on board routing
server
show them a previous slide this is a
complex diagram and I don't expect you
to know everything but I want to just
point to the Python parts so this is
Python right on board the locomotive the
cosmic application well it stands for
CSX onboard systems management agent and
systems management in the sense that
it's it's managing all these systems and
checking them out there's three Python
applications two of them are on the
onboard value server this is a main
program positive it and this is
accomplished supervisor application its
job is to start and stop Kozma to make
sure cops are still running if Cosmo
stops running it will start a new
instance of Cosmo there's another oh you
can see look on the locomotive messaging
server the top arrow there's something
called the plasma auxiliary agent kind
of romantic name there but it's it's on
another one it's on a box so component
of the train ptc train computer that
kills with messaging and it's it's job
is to listen to Kozma and make sure that
if Kozma stop sending messages it will
alert to the back office send an alert
so someone will try to find out why
okay causes primary functions there's
several primary functions that it has to
check out GBC equipment before it gets
deployed in the field and this is this
is a new GE locomotive and this is the
kind of environment that you might see
when they're installed a positive train
control equipment on the locomotives for
the first time and Kozma will when they
install that rowdy server and they turn
it on and they run cosmic Cosmo will
check all the PGC related devices and
make a report to let them know how many
of the devices are working and how they
are installed and whether it's good to
go to the next step and a sketch stage
another Cosmo function is to report
problems that it detects while the
locomotive is running or when it stops
but normally when it's running and also
to correct problems if it detects
certain certain classes of problems in
this case we see a report that this is a
console in an office in office and when
we blow up you see that cause the same
without the ATM T cell phone is powered
off and I'm going to try to power it off
so it not only monitors for problems but
it also in some cases that tries to
correct the problem it also reports
signal strength from the various Wi-Fi
sources on war as I mentioned we've got
a TTL modem and a verizon cell phone a
Wi-Fi and radio and it's sitting Kozma
as the Train moves it's it's recording
the signal strength from all of those
devices and sending basically like this
telemetry data every 400 feet back to
the office and this is the graph that i
created a public website i whip some of
that data that shows
an area of interest around the center of
the graph and you can see that there
it's hard to see from the small legend
but the purple and blue are stronger
signals and the other colors are weaker
signals and this is the part they were
interested in and it turned out to kind
of three strong signal for the verizon
cell phone another function is to
perform software updates to onboard
systems either in the shop or on the
rail so cosmati is being developed now
it's not one of the first versions of
Kozma is being put on test locomotives
to update system software for these
various onboard devices and it can
happen either whether look whether it is
in the shop or when it's out running in
our city this is the section on
programming in Kozma because it's about
Python and I've only had one pythons
omeros there so now python programming
on the locomotive on this cosmic is not
really rocket science compared to
awesome applications like Patrick's and
ones that will hear about but I from my
from my understanding of the group and
from getting to know some of the people
i know that there's a wide variety of
experience in career for your paths so i
thought it might be very useful and
interesting to have this respect to you
could probably think of some unusual
circumstances are unusual restriction
that you may have when you're
programming an application that runs on
a moving locomotive and well we have
some of them here we're not allowed to
interfere with the proper functioning of
any safety code critical systems Kozma
is not designated as a safety critical
system so that if Cosmo stops running
ptc will still work but it will just
take longer for people to find out
there's something going wrong if things
we were wrong we can be in and out of
connectivity we may be in a place where
there's radio towers and cell towers and
GPS where we could be in a mountain in
our town and we could be out of
connectivity so we can't make any
assumptions about when we can send
messages or even really when we can
interface with the other onboard systems
because there's something to be turned
on or off their circuit breakers in the
event and trip we can we don't have a
controlled shutdown when we code we're
sort of ingrained behind a program to do
some initialized initialization when we
start and then when we shut down we do
some shut down so that when we
initialize next it'll be a smooth
initialization but the shutdown in for
Kozma is the engineer turning a circuit
breaker off and powers disconnected from
the machine so we don't have a
controlled shutdown we also know that
cell been with is very expensive when I
go over my AT&T cell modem plan by a
gigabyte 18t charges me about 15 bucks
but if I go over the my cell plan with a
gigabyte with the high availability
contract at CSX has with ATT you can add
a couple of zeros or two or three zeros
and we also or not this is a minor thing
but we're not really allowed to do much
writing to the hard drive because it's a
solid state drive and these wear out
over time and they're trying to minimize
the where so that they can last as long
as possible because what you have to
respond so I hardware on the locomotor
that's expensive especially when the
rail when the locomotive is what is
powering year
for your company another big deal is
that we have to stay aware where changes
in the onboard environment that when you
write a program you really know unless
it's a mobile app you may be you may be
secure and knowing that things are going
to be about the same when you start one
time is when you start as before but we
can't make that assumption they may take
the awkward routing server off the
locomotive and put it on a different
locomotive and turn it on and we may
know if we wake up on a new locomotive
and start broadcasting to the back
office saying we're the old locomotive
that's going to cause problems so we
have to be aware one locomotive we're on
some of the monitoring that we do like
the signal strength mapping is really
relevant only when we're in our own home
territory cSX's territory is about
territory is east of the Mississippi and
trains go west of the Mississippi they
go north in Canada but we don't really
need to map their cell modem single
train so we turn that off we're out of
home care to it so it's like geofence
the positive train control state can
change as well we we saw before that the
system was warning saying positive train
control is about to break we saw another
time which says I'm trying to initialize
but I can't get in touch we saw another
time when it said I'm raking that's
called enforcing if the PCC computer is
counting down saying 10 9 about to break
in eight seconds we're not going to say
here's your software upgrade
so we have to be aware of what state the
computer is in and our programming my
resistor dress hat it's red hat
enterprise linux server and we run
python 2.6 16 and it's you know it's not
that bad it's actually very first we
thought well pythons up pythons up to
2.7 points something and but when we
started coding in python 2.6 160 was
really pretty good and there's only a
couple of gotchas that we've run across
a none of them early world rock it's a
multi-threaded application and just um
it's about the least likely candidates
for parallelization that you could
imagine because all the threads hardly
do any work they there's a friend
dedicated basis you every kind of
condition that should be monitored and
most of the friends sleeve for most of
the time so it's really an ideal
application of type on multi threading
because when you hear about Python
multithreading you may say oh you know
they're falling into that pitfall of
trying to do some cpu intensive
processing while other while a UI is
running but we none of our processes are
CPU intensive they're all I oh man
they're all basically time around they
wake up check something and go back to
sleep although the single mapping thread
that map's the the the signal strength
says it goes it has to send a single
every 400 feet so it can't just wait on
can set a timer wake up it has to be
aware of where that were that where the
locomotive is my checking GPS okay so
code now I'm
you don't have to look at this code it's
too too closely I wanted to make sure
that the code that's interesting to look
at it's really you can if it piques your
interest you can look at it later but
the idea here is that there's a big
thing here a small in here this is a
config file like a name can any initial
any format with a section and and in an
entry tail to the section we this is a
pattern that we use to configuration
files one is installed with with Kozma
on the locomotive in the environment and
one is the override music file that the
program maintains as it runs and that
helps us that has a couple of good
results one is that we spend less time
riding to the hard drive if we need to
upgrade we never write to the default
config which is very big and also when
when Michael Kozma is upgraded there
will be a new default configuration file
but we'll stay sane or any overrides
that we've saved in our I configuration
file so we'll have all those same
overrides which were desired and this is
this is an example this is the most
simple example that you'll ever see
really at one of these pipe on meetings
we when we're getting a strange from the
config there's a class called cosmic
config it checks the override config if
it finds it it uses that if it doesn't
find it use a good fall contain
this is there's another pattern that we
use are sometimes configuration berries
Kozma is a dynamically update of all
devices configurable over the wire
somebody from the back office can send a
message saying change this thread
interval from 60 seconds to 2 minutes
and you have to upgrade updates
configuration at that time so it's
almost second nature for coders like me
to in the initialization part of your
class read your configuration parameters
and use them during the main bulk of the
code but wait as you can see here
there's not much being initialized in
the event but when you'll get a GPS
drink we read the IP address the time
out from the config before we get our
our gps trim from from one of the
communication devices
this is also another pattern is that we
don't want to overtax onboard systems if
the if the thread is sleeping for three
minutes and wakes up it has to do some
sampling probably a minute or two
minutes of freshness is good enough if
it's been sampled recently and if
several threads happen to wake at the
same time why do you have to know what
the IP address of the cell phone three
times in one second so we have this
pattern where if we query the device we
specify what freshness of data we need
and then the class will just give us the
cached version is what it has is fresh
enough it's not it will resemble we have
this pattern of a neutral facade adapter
because as I mentioned one of the some
of the devices are different depending
on which locomotive it is that the
business code doesn't mean to
differentiate we don't want it to have
to differentiate at runtime so the
business code has an interface that it
can that you mean whether or from the GE
version of Al Gore grounding server or
on the one from Holmen technologies
you may think it's funny that we that
have a slide on commenting we actually
if you ever go to work at CSX
corporation and if you do i'll be happy
to get to know you if i'm still there
which I hope to be there my client they
are dedicating to safety for not in
every aspect of the organization and if
you're ever around people to work for
CSX that will come through clearly
because in every aspect of their
organization there and they're
pretending it's to safety so we have to
when we write our comments and we write
our and weep over view comments we have
to think of them in terms of how they
would look in a federal investigation of
a serious train crash so I have a few
hardware access methods that we use UDP
a lot of these devices on board l
broadcast community so that eliminates
the problem of over taxing them will
never over tax because they'll just ping
ping us will receive it when when we get
it the problem is that we could not all
devices are broadcasting and that the
device determines the sample rate and we
can turn
we this is an example you don't have to
read it but it's it's a socket class a
unity connection class that creates a
socket based on whether you're sending
receiving or receiving a broadcast and
if it took us a long time to get this
right and I thought that if this helps
either one person maybe this ten seconds
will oppose it worth it we another
hardware access method is SNMP does
anyone here have any experience with
SNMP or know what it is it's a
networking protocol that's part of the
IP IP protocol suite that is for
querying networked devices the idea is
that you send a query sign here's the
address I want to query an agent on the
device will respond to that address and
say here the value like here's a
sailboat of let's say here's my idea
another switch might say here's my
configuration version we try two
different SNMP libraries there's a
native see a pipe on one and there's a
pure python implementation
is any we ended up going with this aneta
SNMP version because it's it's much
faster that was a really good critical
thing although if you sailed into the
malformed to Hawaii let's address that
you're hearing it can crash your program
will just Python will stop but now what
we did was we put in checks to make sure
that the OID is not malfunction this is
an SNMP example it's really just for
filing it is the first part of a query
we can be passing the query a dictionary
of demonic step of samples that we want
to take and there Oh IDs their addresses
and it is it as it goes through we
create accessing the status in any
library it creates these bind objects
and then it sends the mind objects and
what it returns is a dictionary with the
same demonic variable names but with the
results for those IDs and I'm not you
don't need to really concentrate too
much on it but if you are interested in
teaneck and you remember this talk it
might save you some time to do this way
because a lot of this a lot of these
libraries are not that well documented
or there's not a lot of activity on the
internet that says how to use them right
you can get the you can get the drive
drive health information is one of the
we monitor and what ibly in some
information that we report and the smart
control utility is was designed to query
information about hard drives and
inevitably the device information that
we need is in these obscure large
integers that have like I'm known
attribute on don't attribute but we have
to get information from the
manufacturers and then parse them bite
by bite or even did my bit to figure out
what it means which one is a power cycle
count health is it expressed in a
floating point number and we report that
because they want to keep track of how
well the solid-state drive is working
housing is I need to be replacing you
can get the drive vendor and model from
your smart control command you can read
a couple parts a couple of 0 files on
the system and you can get the hard
drive and remodel a couple other access
methods you can use telnet and ssh I
won't go into that development and
testing environments we use Eclipse and
hi-def which are just awesome they're
great for our development we can use
them in Windows and Linux and if you're
looking for an integrated development
environment I can I can hardly heartily
recommend them we also use write unit
tests for all of our code and we test
them right in
eclipse with pydev and we also run those
tests which is a command line
application may be familiar with but it
will sniff out all of the all of the
unit tests that it can find in your
forward and run them in after we debug
our code in the development environment
we can test them in a lab this is this
is a verizon lab it's not our verizon
lab but it's very similar to wait them
both over glass where we test and it's
at some of the ptc the onboard equipment
in there so we can actually test it
against the real equipment rather than
against simulators this is a high rental
deal zone it's a vehicle equipped with
some rails that will let it run on the
railroad track I couldn't find a picture
of the visit of screw ptc high real and
it's got the Indies young lord equipment
in the back but i didn't quite a picture
of it on the rail this is the picture
that McCauley i'm a parking lot of CSX
headquarters and jacksonville florida
but that will let you really work out
the differences in white cell signal
strengths and and things that you really
need to be moving to test your
application and it once you're done
testing then every other way there's no
substitute for testing on the real thing
and that guy better get out of the way
unless there's in questions cool is that
that's me
that was great thank you so much we
definitely have time for a couple of
flushing straight so the beginning you
mentioned it's not rocket science
actually what do you think about things
like iphone planes or spacecraft well I
think the the fact that it's being used
for interacting with safety critical
devices makes it suitable for an
application in other transportation in
related news industries and I mean the
number of people at risk in a train
crash is comparable to the number of
people at risk in a plane crash so I
think that having established it in this
railroad industry and probably a good
sign that it's suitable for other other
transportation what level of encryption
you have
your communications this looks like it
could easily be smooth particularly like
the GPS signal some of you just put a
GPS jammer for a pseudo gps transponder
near a train and all of a sudden the
Train things going 200 miles per hour
that that would be a worse that would
not that would affect our application
and we would send erroneous data to the
back office where as we sang we're in
the wrong location it would have a much
worse effect on the safety critical
systems that need to access GPS to make
sure that they're in the right location
and they're not overstepping a red
signal we do have we do use symmetric
keys but not for encrypting only a few
of our messages are signed we and we
have a private key and passphrase and a
public key for the back office our
configuration when configuration
messages come in to tell us to change
the thread interval of this one thread
from one minute to two minute we verify
using those using the public key of the
descending system that is valid that is
signed and when we say when we responded
when they ask is what are what is our
configuration currently when we respond
that assigned as well we currently do
not have any messages that are past that
are deemed to be that mean encryption
so not actually a path one question but
it was really curious about all the use
of wireless center that in the past for
trans the model would be that you'd have
an actual wire cable I'd say this every
time I go home to western Kansas where
there's some old decaying railroad
tracks and the cables are some falling
down so wondering to what extent as
Wireless the future for train signaling
was it already happening
the wire wire is totaled what they call
code line in the railroad industry is
still in use for signaling PTC does not
affect signaling it listens to signaling
and that's what some of these new
wayside devices they're there to do they
read these kodaline signals and tell the
PTC system what the state of the signal
is in there's also another communication
channel which is along the rail itself
because it's conductive there there are
fiber optic you can place a fiber optic
fiber optic fiber along the tracks and
two digits exact vibrations along the
tracks and you can even detect when
someone is walking on the tracks from
very far away using that so i don't
think the cabled even though it's some
other idea that you've seen our decrepit
i don't think the cabling is going away
because of positive train control
awesome last question
if you think that Python will ever be
used in a mission critical role you've
been an observation obviously for
something like like critical mission
critical systems there's certain
requirements deputy for instance and
aerospace applications and medical
applications but I'm curious being
involved in an application like this do
you think practical automating
transition you applied in truly
mission-critical old lab critical roles
I think it has the potential to I think
it's establishing itself as a mainstream
programming language and the fact that
more and more people are adopting it and
even you can make the argument that
Kozma is a mission critical in life I'm
certainly mission critical you can make
the argument that pipe that Kozma is a
life critical application because if we
have a bug in our software we could
disrupt the functioning of the safety
system like we could try to install
software on the treatment positive train
control computer while it's trying to
deciding whether to enforce the breaking
or not so in that sense CSX has made
this decision that python is an
acceptable language in that put in that
application as far as other
mission-critical applications or light
critical applications I had to be honest
I don't know how far python has already
dug into those or whether it up or
whether there's a male obstacle to doing
that